Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir schauen uns auf den Fußballfest.
Matthias, du warst ja auch bei einigen anderen Events, also jetzt nicht nur im Stadion, hast du am Anfang erzählt. Wie war es denn zum Beispiel auf Fan Main? Da warst du doch auch vor Ort.
Ja, also meine Beobachtungen beginnen eigentlich am Tag des Eröffnungsspiels, als ich mit dem Zug von Köln hingefahren bin, mit dem Thalys, und die erste Begegnung mit schwer bewaffneten Polizisten und Militärs in Brüssel hatte, als sechs Mann durch den Zug sind und quasi den ganzen Zug durchsucht haben. In Brüssel habe ich gedacht, hallo, jetzt nähern wir uns Paris und jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt, wie das noch weitergeht. Und in Paris war es dann tatsächlich so, als ich angekommen bin auf dem Bahnhof, unendlich viele Polizisten, unendlich viele Soldaten an jeder Ecke, immer in drei, vier Mann-Grüppchen unterwegs, mindestens einer immer mit einem großen Gewehr oder einer Maschinenpistole umgehängt. Das war absolut respekt-einflößend für mich an dem ersten Tag. Und ich bin dann auch zu einem, direkt zu einem ersten Rundgang gestartet durch Paris und habe mir so ein paar Punkte mal angeguckt. Und egal, wo man unterwegs war, an der Metrostation, an den touristischen Sehenswürdigkeiten, sagen wir mal Louvre, Champs-Élysées, Eiffelturm, Montmartre mit Sacre-Cœur, egal wo man war, überall unglaublich viele Polizeistreifen. Die hatten also, ich habe das Gefühl, sehr viel Angst auch an diesem Eröffnungstag. Und dann bin ich zur Fan-Meile auch gegangen am Eiffelturm und gebe freimütig und offen zu. Ich hatte tatsächlich ein bisschen mulmiges Gefühl, auch vor der Europameisterschaft habe immer gesagt, im Stadion, glaube ich, ist man relativ sicher, weil man das relativ gut schützen kann, durch die Eingänge und durch die Polizei. Aber Fan-Meile, 100.000 Leute auf freiem Feld, Eiffelturm, habe ich Respekt vor. Und da bin ich hin und habe mir das auch genau unter dem Punkt angeguckt. Deutlich mehr Kontrollen am Stadion, war zumindest mein Eindruck. Also man ist erstmal durch so einen ersten äußeren Ring gegangen. Das ist mir jetzt im Prinzip mit dem Hintergrund von Nizza auch nochmal bewusst geworden, dass dieser äußere Ring tatsächlich schon wie eine erste Kontrolle war, weil nämlich dort Polizeivagen, so Mannschaftswagen, so Bullis, wäre und verkeilt auf der Straße standen, dass eben kein LKW da durchfahren kann. Und da standen schon mal an jeder Straße 7, 8, 9 Polizisten, die haben einen nicht kontrolliert. Die haben einen einfach, ich sag mal, angeschaut und geguckt, was kommen denn da für Leute. Und da konnte man eigentlich relativ leicht vorbeigehen. Und dann kam die erste Polizeikontrolle mit erste Rucksackkontrolle und Leibesvisitation, die in unterschiedlichsten Stärken war, so wie Tobi das beschrieben hat, von einmal kurz Beine abklopfen bis hinzu, jetzt dreh dich mal um und ich tasse dich von hinten ab, dass du ja keinen Mist machen kannst, während ich hier dich abtaste. Und dann ging es noch einen Gang weiter, die eigentliche Sicherheitskontrolle, da habe ich auch alles erlebt, von flüchtiger Blick in den Rucksack bis hinzu, jetzt lärst du den Rucksack mal bitte auf dem Tisch aus. Und nochmal Leibesvisitation, also da war ich dann, ich war relativ häufig auf der Fanzone und ich muss gestehen, da habe ich mich sehr, sehr sicher gefühlt im Vergleich zu dem Gefühl, was ich hatte, als ich hingefahren bin nach Paris. Und das hat sich auch nicht geändert über das Turnier eigentlich, da hat es kleinere Zwischenfälle mit Feuerwerkskörpern oder so gegeben, aber das war eigentlich unerheblich. Und an die Militärpräsenz und an die Polizeipräsenz hat man sich ehrlicherweise total gewöhnt. Also, das war einfach klar. Es ist einem schon gar nicht mehr aufgefallen, dass einem mal wieder vier bis an die Zähne bewaffnete Soldaten entgegengekommen sind. Das hat man einfach so hingenommen, das gehört es im Stadtbild und zur Europameisterschaft dazu. Und das ist auch bei den Parisern so. Die sind total daran gewöhnt und das ist alles völlig in Ordnung. Und die wissen auch, dass man manchmal auch auf der Straße einfach kontrolliert wird. Das wissen die Pariser und da wehrt sich auch keiner. Und das ist alles völlig d'accord für alle eigentlich, die da waren. Und das ist relativ entspannt abgelaufen und hat mir dann ein Gefühl von Sicherheit auch vermittelt. Und das hat sich ja dann im Endeffekt auch Gott sei Dank als Wahr herausgestellt, dass da nichts passiert ist.
Ging mir übrigens ähnlich wie dir, Matthias. Fanmeile, ich musste halt nicht hin. Ich hatte da keinen Auftrag. Ich habe tatsächlich bei der ersten Tour einen durchgehenden Bogen drum gemacht. Und da sind wir dann wieder beim Fanclub Nationalmannschaft auf dem Campingplatz des Fanclubs Nationalmannschaft in Paris gewohnt. So ein bisschen außerhalb im Westen, aber grundsätzlich ganz gut gelegen und eine günstige Alternative gewesen zum Hotel. Und haben dort dann die Spiele geguckt und sind nicht reingefahren nach Paris zur Fanmeile, weil wir es halt nicht mussten. Haben wir es dann einfach auch gelassen. Meine ersten Fanmeilenbesuche waren dann im weiteren Turnierverlauf, als ich dann in der K.o. Runde, ich glaube, in Bordeaux waren wir auf der Fanmeile zumindest mal umzugucken, weil da war ja nur ein Spiel, der spielt ja nur Deutschland gegen Italien. Haben wir uns trotzdem die Fanmeile angeguckt.
Wunderschön gelegen auf einem tollen Platz.
Fantastisch, ganz großartig gemacht in Bordeaux. Stückchen besser wahrscheinlich sogar noch in Lyon fand ich. Da liegt es dann auch mitten in der City. Und in Lyon war es tatsächlich so, dass diese Flughafen-Piep-Dinger, wo man so durchgeht, und man gibt seine Metallgegenstände abläuft, dann da durch und dann piept es oder piept halt auch nicht, die gab es in Lyon tatsächlich zur Kontrolle. Ich weiß nicht, wie das abends abläuft, wenn das Spiel war, wir waren nachmittags da oder vormittags, oder gegen Mittag, ist auch egal, waren wir da, haben uns das angeguckt, was da so los ist, weil es dann halt auch erst meine zweite Fan-Meile war, obwohl wir schon im Halbfinale waren. Aber ich muss auch echt sagen, da haben die wirklich einen sehr intensiven Job gemacht. Und ich habe auf diesem Campingplatz in Paris noch eine Geschichte von unseren Nachbarn, die quasi nebenan gewohnt haben, gehört. Die fand ich sehr beeindruckend. Der hat sich bei den fliegenden Händlern, Matthias wird sie kennen, die diese kleinen Eiffeltürme verkaufen. Da hat er sich so einen kleinen Eiffelturm gekauft und wollte dann hinterher leichtsinnig, wie er war, auf die Fernmeile gehen. Und das fand der Typ am Einlass aber überhaupt nicht witzig. Und dann musste er zu diesem Häuschen, da konnte man seine Sachen abgeben. Da hat er diesen Eiffelturm, der war vielleicht 15 Zentimeter oder so, hat er den dort abgegeben, hat sich das Spiel angeguckt und ist nach dem Spiel da wieder hin und wollte den Eiffelturm wieder abholen. Und dachte sich, naja gut, jetzt hole ich den Eiffelturm ab und dann gehe ich hier raus und dann ist gut. Ja, Pustekuchen. Da musste erst ein Ordner kommen, der hat den Eiffelturm in die Hand genommen. Dann ist er mit diesem Bekannten bis zum Ausgang. 100 Meter. Diese Fanmeile war ja riesengroß in Paris. Gelaufen, hat ihn nicht aus der Hand gegeben und hat dann als der Kumpel, die Fanmeile verlassen hat, da hat er ihm den Eiffelturm in die Hand gedrückt und hat gesagt, noch zu seinem Ordnerkollegen, der kommt hier nicht wieder rein mit dem Eiffelturm. Also, die haben sich wirklich schon gerade bei den Fanmeilen sehr, sehr große Mühe gegeben und ich kann voll und ganz verstehen, wenn du sagst, dass du am Anfang Sorgen hattest, aber die quasi mit den Erlebnissen vor Ort dann wieder revidiert wurden.
Ich mache noch zwei kleine Ergänzungen auch wieder, so wie gerade. Ich habe einen Touristen oder einen Fan erlebt, der fast verzweifelt war, weil ihm die Kontrolle seine Powerbank weggenommen hat. Das ist aber auch schlimm. Das ist ein Wurfgeschoss und er sagt, ich habe aber kein Akku mehr und ich muss hier meinen Handy laden und ich brauche das Ding und ich habe keine Bombe bei mir, ich will nur meinen Handy laden und das ist völlig und es war ein riesen Theater mit vier, fünf Ordnern, die da waren. Und eine andere Beobachtung, die deckt sich ein bisschen mit dem, was Raphael Buschmann im Spiegel geschrieben hat, jetzt zum Finale, der ja so ein bisschen mutig versucht hat, die Sicherheitskontrollen zu umgehen und die auch eine Menge geschafft hat, bis hin, dass er in der deutschen Kabine gesessen hat und auf dem Rasen gestanden ist. Es gab einen Tag, ich hatte mein Mikrofon dabei, weil ich ein Interview oder weil ich Fans interviewen wollte auf der Fanmeile und dieses Mikrofon ist ein relativ großer, schwerer Knochen, weil da auch die Aufnahmeeinheit und die Batterien und alles drin ist, also das ist relativ schwer und groß, würde eindeutig auch als Schlagstock durchgehen. Und das war ein Tag, wo es sehr nervös war, weil da Proteste in Paris waren, die in die Nähe der Fanmeile gezogen sind, wegen dieser Arbeitsmarktreform. Und da waren mehrere Eingänge zu an der Fanmeile, wo man gar nicht drauf konnte, aus Sicherheitsgründen, dass die Protestler da gar nicht in die Nähe dieser Eingänge kommen. Ich musste quasi, weil ich genau an der Stelle war, wo ich eigentlich drauf wollte, der war dann gesperrt, einmal um das ganze Marsfeld laufen. Da ist man gefühlt eine halbe Stunde unterwegs, bis man auf der anderen Seite ist. Und bin dann an einen Eingang und habe gesagt, so, ich möchte jetzt hier gerne rein. Und dann sagte die Ordnerin, die meinen Rucksack tatsächlich komplett ausgeleert hat, was ist das? Ja, ein Mikrofon. Nein, geht nicht. Ich sage, ich bin Journalist, ich möchte hier arbeiten, ich bin Interviewsführend. Nein, geht nicht. Müsste hier abgegeben werden an der Deposit-Stelle. Und dann habe ich gesagt, geht nicht, ich möchte hier arbeiten, ich muss Interviews führen. Hier ist meine Akkreditierung, habe meine UEFA-Akkreditierung rausgeholt und ich habe gesagt, ich habe das alle Tage hier gemacht. Überhaupt kein Ding, ich bin also ich möchte hier arbeiten. Nein, geht nicht, sie muss einen Chef holen. Okay, dann kam der Chef und hat gesagt, ich bräuchte eine extra Akkreditierung für die Fanzone. Und ich habe gesagt, die habe ich aber nicht. Ich habe meine UEFA-Akkreditierung und ich möchte einfach hier arbeiten, Interviews führen. Nein, das funktioniert nicht. Ich könnte das jetzt abgeben oder ich könnte nach Hause gehen oder ich könnte es an einem anderen Eingang versuchen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, dann gehe ich zum anderen Eingang. Und da hat der Kollege gesagt, was ist das? Ich habe gesagt, Mikrofon.
Aber, glaube ich dir, genau so haben es fast alle Leute gemacht. Und diese Powerbank-Geschichte vor mir glaube ich vier bis acht Mal bei elf Spielen erlebt, dass in der Schlange beim Kontrollieren die Leute ihre Powerbank nicht mit reinnehmen durften, weil sie zu groß war, weil sie überhaupt eine Powerbank war, keine Ahnung. Ich habe mir tatsächlich vor dem Turnier eine gekauft, die von der Fläche her so groß ist wie eine EC-Karte und dann halt, weiß ich nicht, so dick wie sechs EC-Karten, die kannst du ins Portemonnaie packen. Es hat nicht einmal einer ins Portemonnaie geguckt. Dementsprechend hatte ich die Powerbank immer mit im Stadion. Aber tatsächlich ist die Lösung, gehen sie zu einem anderen Eingang, ist die einzige, die dich dann auch wirklich in solchen Situationen dahin bringt, wo du hinmöchtest. Aber natürlich auch die bösen Jungs dahin bringen, wo sie hinmöchten.
Ja, das ist vielleicht nur ein interessanter Punkt. Da kam nämlich auch eine höhere Frage. Denn das eine ist ja die Sicherheit der Fanmine und der Zone rund ums Stadion. Und Matthias hat es ja schon angesprochen, ein Stadion selbst, wenn man innen drin ist, da hat man nochmal gewisse Sicherheitsmechanismen schon überwunden, die andere nicht so leicht überwinden können. Und dennoch kam es jetzt auch bei dieser EM dazu, dass Bengalos geschmissen wurden, zum Teil ja sogar. Es gab Böller, es gab Leuchtraketen und ein bisschen ein anderes Thema, aber auch die vielen Flitzer haben zumindest in meinem Umfeld für einiges verwundern gesorgt. Wie empfandet ihr denn die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen innerhalb der Stadien und kann man da den Veranstaltern überhaupt einen Vorwurf machen? Denn mir ist keine Liga dieser Welt bekannt, die es hinbekommt, Bengalos, Böller und ähnliche Dinge aus Stadien fernzuhalten.
Ich finde, 100 Prozent abhalten kann man das nicht. Ich habe es im Stadion selber nur ein paar Mal gesehen, dass dann nach einem Tor irgendwie so eine Fackel hochgehalten wurde. Das war jetzt auch irgendwie alles nicht dramatisch, aber man hat es natürlich trotzdem gesehen. Ich habe es einmal auf einer Fanzone gesehen. Da war, ich glaube, es war Türkei gegen Kroatien. Da hat es ein bisschen so eine kleine Schubserei gegeben und da wurde ein Böller gezogen. Da waren wir kurz Hallo auf der Fanzone. Da war auch ein bisschen Bewegung. Aber da haben die Sicherheitskräfte sofort reagiert, diesen Böller unter den nächsten Bauzaun geschoben und da war sofort wieder Ruhe. Also da haben sie auch super reagiert. Ich habe einen Bericht gelesen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das auch in dem Spiegelbericht von dem Raphael Wuschmann war. Ich glaube, dass bei diesem Spiel, wo es diese schlimmen oder in Anführungsstrichen die schlimmsten Ausschreitungen mit Feuerwerkskörpern gab, das war ja Kroatien gegen Tschechien, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. In Zhajtien war das, glaube ich, auch, dass da die schon am Tag vorher ins Stadion gebracht wurden, also dass die schon quasi über Nacht da waren und dass sich die Fangruppen quasi Schlachtpläne gemacht hatten, richtig mit detaillierten Verlaufsplänen, an welchem Eingang sie was mit reinbekommen und wo der sicherste Eingang ist. Und das sind halt die Dinge, die dann einen so ein bisschen beunruhigen, dass da so generalstabsmäßig das vorbereitet werden kann, dass man das so generalstabsmäßig auschecken kann, wo es am leichtesten geht und sich da sogar Pläne schreiben kann. Also das ist, finde ich, das, was mich beunruhigt, dass dann mal ein Feuerwerkskörper im Stadion ist oder mal so eine Fackel da gezündet wird bei dem Tor.
Du kannst es halt nicht ändern. Also ich habe ja gesagt, du wurdest mal so, mal so abgetastet und 100 Prozent kriegst du da niemals raus. Was mich im Stadion fast schon schockiert hat, ich glaube, es war Rumänien gegen die Schweiz, als die Rumänen das 1-0 geschossen haben. Wir saßen auf der Seite der Schweizer und hatten den Blick dann dementsprechend im Prinzenpark auf die Seite der Rumänen. Und man konnte ganz klar sehen, da gab es viele Blöcke, die für die Fans vorgesehen waren. Und dann gab es einen Block, der direkt daran anschloss. Dort waren nur schwarzgekleidete junge Männer, sage ich jetzt mal, so im Schnitt. Also man konnte das aus der Ferne relativ gut sehen. Die gehörten zu den Rumänen, hatten keine Trikots an. Und als die Rumänen dann das 1-0 geschossen haben, in der 18. Minute, wo brannten natürlich die Pyros, genau in dem Block. Also die hatten komplett diesen ganzen Block für sich alleine, hatten auch die Ordner drum herum stehen. Und dann zünden die diese Pyros an. Und ich weiß ja nicht, in Hannover ist es zumindest Standard. Dann brennt das Ding ab. Und dann ist das Thema auch in Ordnung. Und dann werfen die das weg. Bei dem Turnier sind die Ordner in den Block rein und haben denen die brennenden Pyros aus der Hand gerissen. Also, ich weiß nicht, das haben die sich ja wahrscheinlich nicht ausgedacht, die Ordner. Also, wenn die einigermaßen beigegangen sind, machen sie das ja nicht. Das muss ja also eine Ansage gewesen sein. Ich hab's noch bei irgendeinem anderen Spiel, ich krieg's jetzt nicht mehr zusammen. Ich glaube, es war Polen gegen Portugal, das Viertelfinale in Marseille, auch beobachten können, dass dort brennende Fackeln aus der Hand gerissen werden. Und dann irgendwie möglich so, dass man sie nicht sieht hinter irgendwelche Banden oder rausgebracht oder wie auch immer, je nachdem, in welchem Bereich des Steilungs das ist. Das fand ich schon ziemlich extrem. In meinen Augen sehr leichtsinnig, aber die werden schon wissen, was sie tun. Ich hoffe zumindest, dass sie wussten, was sie tun. Die Ordner in dem Moment. Das war so eine Beobachtung aus dem Stadion, wo ich dachte, wow, ganz unangenehme Geschichte. Matthias, du hast es ja wahrscheinlich auch gesehen, dass man mit Seilen gearbeitet hat im Innenraum. Ganz großartig. Ich musste immer lachen.
UEFA 2016-Style.
Du möchtest natürlich verhindern, dass irgendwelche Flitzer in den Stadion-Innenbereich kommen.
Dann spannt sie ins Seil oder was?
Du hast dann natürlich die Ordner positioniert und während du spielst kannst du nicht auf einer, weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich 400 Meter langen Bahn alle 10 cm einen Ordner hinstellen. Also stellst du alle drei oder vier Meter einen hin und die haben einen Seil in der Hand. Das halten die in der Hand und dann geht das wieder runter und beim nächsten Ordner geht das wieder hoch. Und in dem Moment, wo einer versucht, da durchzubrechen, versuchen sie das Seil halt hochzuziehen und damit den Flitzer zum Straucheln oder zum Erliegen zu bringen. Ich habe, glaube ich, zwei oder drei Flitzer live gesehen im Stadion, sind aber immer auf der anderen Seite des Stadions abgehauen. Deshalb kann ich nicht sehen, was sie mit diesem Seil tatsächlich veranstaltet haben. Ich kann es mir nur so erklären, dass sie versuchen, mit diesem Seil mehrere Flitzer aufzuhalten und so quasi zum Straucheln zu bringen. Das sah immer ein bisschen unbeholfen aus.
Aber diese Seile sind ja auch noch für einen anderen Zweck eingesetzt worden. Das kommt man immer kurz vor dem Anpfiff beobachten. Ein Bild für die Götter, muss man sagen. Da wurden Podeste aufgebaut für die Fotografen, damit die die Mannschaftsfotos machen konnten und dann eben das Einlaufen der Mannschaften aus dem Kabinengang. Und diese Podeste standen quasi am Rand der Coachingzone. Es wurden so kleine Podeste hingestellt, wo dann sich die, weiß ich nicht, 35 Journalisten, 35 Fotografen auf jeder Seite drauf färchen konnten, um da diese berühmten Mannschaftsfotos für die Sonderhefte zu knipsen, wo die elf Spieler alteinander stehen. Und die Journalisten wurden dann immer, das war ja ein unglaubliches Zeremoniell, mit dieser Eröffnungsfeier vor jedem Spiel. Und dann wurden die Journalisten durch einen, oder die Fotografen durch einen, durch einen Seiteneingang rein geführt. Und zwar immer in einem Pulk zusammen. Und rund um den Pulk wurden, liefen sechs Ordner. Und die hatten drei Seile gespannt. An jeder Seite eins und vorne quer eins. Damit keiner von den Fotografen es wagte, auszubüxen und alle schön in den Pulk, genau zu dem Podest geführt werden konnten. Und dann durften die auf das Podest drauf und ihre Fotos machen. Und danach wurden die schön wieder weggeführt und hatten ja dann alle ihre Sitze rund um die Banden, dass sie dann die Hintertorfotografen und die, was weiß ich, wo die alle sitzen. Das war absolut lächerlich, weil das sind professionelle Kollegen, die machen da ihre Arbeit. Von denen hat keiner irgendwie Interesse, ein Stück Rasen rauszuschneiden oder sonst irgendwas zu machen. Die wollen einfach nur möglichst schnell einen guten Platz auf diesem Podest haben, um da ihr Foto zu machen, was sie an die Agitur verkaufen oder in ihrer Zeitung. Und die müssen da zwischen Leinen laufen, damit sie ja nicht irgendwie einen halben Meter zu weit. Absolut lächerlich.
Immer wieder ein schönes Bild.
Und im Nachhinein weiß man, man hätte diese Leinen eher um die Kinder Jugendlichen machen sollen, die damit beschäftigt waren, die großen Trikots aufzuspannen und das große UEFA-Logo zu drehen. Da kamen ja dann die Selfie-Jäger her, die Cristiano Ronaldo noch geknipst haben.
Ja, aber ich finde gerade er ist ja auch ein Beispiel dafür, wie man das gut mit Humor nehmen kann.
Absolut. Wie ist denn das, wenn man David Guetta so, ich würde mal sagen, in 30 Tagen gefühlt 15, 16 Mal auf voller Lautstärke hört?
15, 16 Mal? Das ist der Tagesration!
Das schallt ja überall her, auf der Fan-Meile überall. Also ich bin ganz ehrlich, es ist überhaupt nicht meine Musik. Ich finde aber, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich gesprochen, dass der Schlussteil seiner Musik, die dann immer gespielt wurde, als die Mannschaften reinkamen, wo er seine Musik irgendwie in fast schon was pathetisches verwandelt hat, irgendwie hatte das was. Ich weiß nicht, was es hatte, aber irgendwie hatte das was. Man hat sich irgendwie dann aber dann einfach dran gehört und das dann so beim spätestens dritten Mal, ja, das war halt so und das war halt die Erkennungsmelodie. Man wusste genau, was jetzt passiert. Und da man diese Eröffnungsfeier, die ja auch immer gleich waren bei jedem Spiel, man konnte die Schritte ja quasi auf der Tribüne schon mittanzen, beim dritten Mal. Das war ja alles ein absolut überbordendes Zeremoniell fast schon. Aber um bei David Guetta zu bleiben, irgendwie hatte seine Musik was, aber es ist einfach nicht meine.
Du weißt nicht genau, was.
Meine ist auch nicht, aber so für ein- zweimal Gänsehaut hat es gereicht.
Okay.
Vielleicht lag es nicht zwingend an ihm, sondern einfach an meinem ersten EM-Spiel oder dass es Halbfinale war oder was auch immer. Aber es war schon nicht so ganz schlecht organisiert und geplant von UEFA. Und da muss man auch wirklich diese ganzen Kinder, ob sie dann uns Selfies machen oder nicht, aber das Getanze und so. Man kann das schlechter machen. Und ich finde, es wird ja auch immer gerne und auch völlig zu Recht über Eröffnungs- und Abschlussfeiern gemeckert. Eröffnungsfeier habe ich nicht gesehen, da war ich noch zu Hause und habe es auch im Fernsehen tatsächlich nicht gesehen. Aber die Abschlussfeier, das war doch, das war kurz und knackig und da hat man nicht mehr gemacht als nötig. Und man hat auch wirklich erst ein Viertel von Neun angefangen, so wie bei allen Spielen sowieso auch. Ja, es gehört so ein Stück weiter zu, aber ich fand es insgesamt nicht so schlecht gemacht. Ich würde aber vor noch ganz kurz gerne noch mal Max den Schwung zurück zur Sicherheit machen. Eine Geschichte, die ich noch zwingend loswerden muss, das war das Halbfinale in Marseille, Deutschland gegen Frankreich. Ich glaube, die Franzosen, ich weiß nicht, wann haben sie das 2-0 geschossen? Das muss irgendwie so in der 75. Minute gewesen sein. Ich kriege es gar nicht mehr zusammen. Ich möchte mich auch vielleicht gar nicht daran erinnern. Und dann sind meine Frau und ich kurz mal noch was trinken und auf Toilette gegangen und dachten uns, okay, vielleicht geht gleich noch mal was. Wir waren dann quasi hinter der Tribüne, da ist ein relativ großer Bereich gewesen, wo man sich frei aufhalten konnte. Aber auch der Zaun, der geschlossen war und eine Tür offen hatte, von vielleicht 10, 15 Türen, die die Leute in- und aus dem Stadion rausließen. Aber offensichtlich war der Zaun nicht weiter bewacht. Es sind tatsächlich in der 75. oder 80. Minute Leute per Räuberleiter in dieses Stadion eingebrochen. Und da hat keiner drauf geachtet. Also der Tag war sowieso so ein bisschen verkorkst, was die Organisation anging und was die Sicherheit anging. Wir mussten nicht wie beim ersten Spiel in Marseille über die Seite, wo die Hauptstraße war, sondern über so eine Nebenstraße rein. Da lief man dann irgendwie gefühlt noch mal eine Stunde, bis man um 22 Häuserblöcke rum war, um dann auf der anderen Seite vom Stadion zu sein. Dort hatten die Ordner eine Reihe aufgemacht, wo man dann die Leute quasi gebremst hat und dann immer blockweise reingelassen hat, damit die dann kontrolliert werden konnten. Das brach dann auch irgendwie um 20.20 Uhr oder so komplett zusammen, und man ließ dann alle Leute auf diese kontrollierenden Ordner zustürmen, die natürlich auch nicht mehr intensiv kontrolliert haben. Also das war so der erste Fail oder nicht ganz geglückte Move von den Sicherheitskräften. Und das wohlgemerkt beim wahrscheinlich fünften oder sechsten Spiel in Marseille. Das war jetzt nicht so, dass die erstmalig so ein Spiel da hatten, sondern das letzte und das Halbfinale dort. Ja, und dann hatten wir diese Szene in der 80. Minute, wo vier Leute auf der anderen Seite vom Zaun standen. Und wie das bei Rollball halt so ist, drei haben es geschafft. Einer ist dann nicht mehr reingekommen. Der hatte keinen, der ihm über den Zaun helfen konnte. Aber die anderen drei, die waren im Stadion. Eine davon hatte eine relativ große und beeindruckende Umhängetasche um. Also so ein Bag zum Umhängen. Gut, offensichtlich hatte er da nichts drin. Aber ich fand es schon erschreckend, dass das überhaupt möglich war, dass die Leute da relativ easy und – das ging vielleicht anderthalb Minuten oder so – in diese Stadion eindringen konnten.
Das ist tatsächlich – ja, interessant ist noch das neutralste Attektiv, was mir dazu einfällt. Ein bisschen bedenklich tatsächlich.
Bedenklich, ja.
Eine Sache kann man noch hinzufügen. Sainte-Denis, Viertelfinale, Frankreich, Island, auf einmal Riesenauflauf. Polizei, gepanzerte Autos, die mit quietschenden Reifen um die Ecken schießen. Ich wollte gerade den Presseeingang nehmen, weil ich eigentlich zu einer Pressekonferenz wollte, die da vor dem Spiel war, und ich durfte nicht weitergehen. Man hat mich angehalten, also jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass es irgendwie gefährlich war, sondern gesagt, jetzt warte mal kurz hier, hier müssen wir gerade mal durch. Und dann sind da sieben, acht, neun, zehn Autos in vollstem Tempo, zum Teil mit absolut verdunkelten Scheiben, vermummte Polizisten an mir vorbei. Ich habe dann nachher gehört, da musste ein Auto gesprengt werden. Ich habe gedacht, das hat man, glaube ich, gar nicht so mitbekommen in Deutschland. Im Endeffekt hat sich das als völlig harmlos herausgestellt, er hatte im Parkverbot gestanden. Und man hat gedacht, das könnte was sein, und dann hat das Auto einfach kurz sein gesprengt.
Füge ich noch meine Geschichte vom Finale dazu. Ich glaube, die gleiche Situation hatte sich abgespielt beim Spiel Deutschland gegen Polen. Da gab es zumindest auch in Deutschland ein Video, was ich gar nicht weiß, von welcher Zeitung er war. Ein Journalist, der hinter der Absperrung stand, da hat man nicht ein Auto, sondern einen Roller gesprengt. Und jetzt beim Finale, Portugal gegen Frankreich, war es dann wieder so, als ich von der Bahn zum Start gegangen bin, auf einmal gab es das große Gehupe und Gefeifer von der Polizei. Man möge sich bitte möglichst schnell dort von dem Ort entfernen. Und da stand dann auch an einem Baum auf diesem Weg ein einsamer, herrenloser Roller. Und die Polizei hat das ratzefatze abgesperrt. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Geschichte ausgegangen ist. Ich habe mich dann schnellstmöglich verdrückt, weil ich mir dachte, es muss ja auch nicht sein. Es ist ja dann auch mehr zum Spaß hier. Wie die Geschichte ausgeht, spielt keine Rolle. Aber die Lunte war sehr, sehr kurz gerade um Start de France herum. Da kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass ein oder andere Roller oder das eine oder andere Auto das Zeitliche gesegnet hat, obwohl er überhaupt nichts Böses gemacht hat.
Ja gut, da werden wahrscheinlich alle zustimmt nicken, wenn man sagt, lieber einmal zu viel vorsichtig sein. Man mag sich, glaube ich, den organisatorischen Aufwand allein an Personnell gar nicht so richtig vorstellen, wie viele Sicherheitskräfte da unterwegs waren. Und jetzt umso makaberer natürlich, dass jetzt direkt nach der EM Frankreich wieder getroffen wird. Das ist sicher auch so kein Zufall. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie ich wollte eigentlich mit euch jetzt über das ganze Prozedere innerhalb des Stadions sprechen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man da den Bogen hinbekommt, ohne allzu pietästlos zu sein. Ich erspare mir mal den Gag, den ich dazu auf den Lippen habe. Einfach, es war ja immer derselbe Ablauf, immer nach festem Protokoll. Für mich als Fernsehzuschauer hatte es den großen Vorteil. Ich habe immer eigentlich bis zum Anpfiff noch gearbeitet oder irgendwas im Haushalt gemacht. Ich hatte immer nur die Vorberichterstattung auf den Ohren. Und so ab, ich glaube, bei CDF war es so, immer nach dem letzten Werbebreak, bevor es dann losging, war die Stadionatmoschule hinterlegt, hinter die Experten. Und dann konnte ich schon anhand der Tracks, die gespielt wurden, erkennen, okay, jetzt sind es noch fünf Minuten, okay, jetzt sind es noch drei Minuten. Aber jetzt kommt der David Guettart-Teil, der mir übrigens auch gefällt. Jetzt drehen sich gleich die Stour dessen von Fly Emirates, war glaube ich der Sponsor, drehen sich gleich und dann kommen die Spieler rein. Okay, jetzt sollte ich dann auch wieder zurück ins Wohnzimmer. Wie empfindet man das denn, wenn man im Stadion ist?
Also, fange ich kurz an. Ich habe vorhin angesprochen, ich bin tatsächlich beim ersten Spiel, wie die UEFA es gerne hätte, drei Stunden vor Spielbeginn in der Nähe des Stadions gewesen, noch nicht im Stadion. Aber man legt das dann sehr schnell ab. Also, ich glaube, man kann da fast eine Gerade ziehen nach oben. Und zum Finale war ich um 20.55 Uhr oder 20.50 Uhr auf meinem Platz und habe mich dann das ganze Drama da angeguckt. Also, ich weiß nicht, man nimmt das halt so mit. Also, ich hatte ja dann, ich weiß nicht, wer es bei Twitter verfolgt hat. Meine Sammelleidenschaft wurde geweckt, als ich den ersten Spieltagsbecher in der Hand hatte. Und da wurden dann am Ende 11 Spieltagsbecher drum. Das heißt, das war immer noch so die Aufgabe, bevor das Spiel losging, dass ich diesen blöden Becher organisiert kriege. Das war nicht immer ganz leicht. Gerade ab Achmelfinale gab es dann halt nicht unendlich von diesen bedruckten Bechern mit den Flaggen drauf. Da war es dann immer ein bisschen schwierig. Aber hat alles immer gut geklappt. Und ich sag mal so, ab Achmelfinale war ich, glaube ich, nie vor 20.30 Uhr im Stadion. Ich habe also diese ganzen Shishis da vorher mir komplett gespart. Und diese 20.45 Geschichte, ja gut. Man musste sie halt mitnehmen. Da ging es nicht anders.
Bisschen zur Kiss-Cam in der Halbzeit dann, ne?
Da waren teilweise wirklich schöne Sachen dabei. Also, das hat man ja offensichtlich aus Amerika geklaut. Das gibt es ja schon seit gefühlten 100 Jahren. Ich finde, da hat man in der Halbzeitpause für gute Stimmung gesorgt.
So grundsätzlich hat er ja auch so ein ewiggleiches Protokoll. Nicht nur seine Nachteile. Was ich übrigens bei den Tanzchoreografien sehr bemerkenswert fand war, dass das zumindest im Anschein nach keine professionellen jugendlichen Tänzergruppen waren, sondern ich hatte den Eindruck, da war von Körper, Größe, Umfang und Alter bei den Jugendlichen so ziemlich alles dabei. Die tanzten auch zum Teil so ein bisschen aus der Reihe. Das Gegenbild ist so ein bisschen, finde ich, die Olympischen Spiele, die Eröffnungsfeier in Peking damals. Da hat man 80.000 Menschen, die exakt gleich sogar dieselbe Frisur haben. Das fand ich aber sehr angenehm, muss ich sagen. Dass ich zumindest da den Eindruck hatte, da durften einfach viele Jugendliche mitmachen, die da drauf Lust hatten und die wurden jetzt auch nicht monatelang gedrillt. Dass das auch wirklich alles genau intakt ist, das fand ich eigentlich ganz schön, muss ich sagen.
Ich fand es auch charmant, muss ich sagen. Ich habe keine Hintergründe, ich habe es auch nicht näher recherchiert, wie es jetzt dazu kam, wer da wann, warum, wie tanzten durfte. Aber tatsächlich Männlein, Weiblein, jung, alt, klein, groß, etwas fülliger, etwas dünner, alles war dabei eigentlich. Das habe ich auch so gesehen.
Das war in der Tat positiv, das sehe ich auch so. Sie haben ja dann auch immer das Publikum mit einbezogen, sind dann auf die Auslinie quasi, einmal rundrum haben sie sich verteilt, haben dann gewunken oder getanzt oder wie auch immer. Ich fand auch, das war einfach nett, das passte so ganz gut dahin. Wenn man schon irgendwas in die Richtung macht, dann lieber tanzende Kinder als Menschen auf rollenden Segways.
Ja gut, das ist ja eh klar. Der Segway unterlegt eigentlich jeder Fortbewegungsvariante. Vielleicht beim Hoverboard gibt es ein knappes Unentschieden. Was haben sich denn die Sponsoren so einfallen lassen? Ich bin mir sicher, sie haben sich was einfallen lassen.
Oh ja, Sponsoren ist ein heikles Thema bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Das ist aus mehreren Gründen heikel, wie ich finde. Vor allen Dingen natürlich wegen der Großsponsoren der UEFA. Da sind ja einige dazugekommen, die in fragwürdigem Licht erscheinen. Ich nenne nur ein Beispiel der aserbaidschanische Stromkonzern Soka, der bei jedem Spiel auf den Banden prangte. Da muss jetzt auch mal kurz deutlich werden, wie UEFA wieder ihr typisches Scheuklappenphänomen anlegt. Sie ist natürlich gefragt worden auf der Abschlusspressekonferenz, was sie denn nun von der Menschenrechtssituation in Aserbaidschan halten und was das nun soll. Auch in dem Hinblick, dass 2020 bei der interkontinentalen, oder sagen wir UEFA-weiten Aserbaidschan liegt ja nicht mal auf europäischem Gebiet, Europameisterschaft, was sie da von der Menschenrechtslage halten. Und da gibt es den klassischen Satz, den sie immer sagen, wir reden über Fußball, alles andere interessiert uns nicht. Ich finde, da müssen sie sich tatsächlich Fragen gefallen lassen. Und das ist wieder ganz typische UEFA. Und das kann man auch FIFA, IOC und wie sie alle heißen dazu nehmen. Das ist einfach das typische Funktionärsgehabe. Da ist die UEFA kein Deut besser als irgendjemand anders. Das ist die eine Geschichte. Eine andere Geschichte ist nicht ganz so gefährlich und nicht ganz so dramatisch. Ich hatte es vorhin schon mal angesprochen, diese Beleuchtung des Eiffelturms. Jeden Abend wurde unter den Mannschaften, die an dem Tag gespielt haben, quasi eine Verlosung gemacht. Und der, der die meisten Erwähnungen auf den Social Media Kanälen hatte, in dessen Landesfarben wurde der Eiffelturm angestrahlt. Das war in der Rekordzahl natürlich Frankreich. Die haben an allen sieben Spieltagen hat der Eiffelturm in französischen Farben gebrannt oder geleuchtet. Außer am Achtelfinaltag, da haben die Deutschen das Rennen gemacht. Das war das einzige Mal, dass es in schwarz-rot-gold war. Die Türken hatten es glaube ich viermal oder dreimal. Da war es allerdings einmal, wurde das aus Solidaritätsgründen wegen des Anschlags in Istanbul gemacht. Das war am Anfang so ein bisschen, sagen die Verantwortlichen, selber eine lahme Veranstaltung. Das hat ein bisschen gebraucht, bis die Leute das verstanden haben. Und dann wurde es eigentlich Kult. Dann haben sich die Fans tatsächlich um 11 Uhr nochmal auf der Fan-Meile versammelt, um das zu sehen und dieses Spektakel zu erleben, wenn der dann in den Landesfarben angestrahlt wird. Es ist wirklich technisch einwandfrei gelöst. Schwarz-rot-gold empfiehlt sich jetzt nicht ganz dafür, weil einfach der halbe Turm schwarz ist. Das ist bei einem Nachtbild nicht so ganz toll. Aber insgesamt extrem beeindruckend, super klar angestrahlt, echt tolle Bilder, die man auch sehen kann im Internet. Das ist aber natürlich eine Sponsor-Aktion, ist ja mal ganz klar. Ich habe da ein bisschen recherchiert, habe auch den Sponsor getroffen. Das ist der größte französische Telefonkonzern. Und die haben ein Konzept aufgelegt, man musste, um damit die Stimme gezählt wird, sowohl den Stromkonzern, add Orange, anschreiben in dem Tweet und dann noch den Hashtag Orange, oder dann auf Englisch Orange Sponsors You. Das heißt, in jedem Tweet, der da gezählt wurde, wurde gleich zweimal der Sponsorname genannt. Also absolut perfektes Marketing, würde ich mal sagen. Und sie haben – ich war kurz vor dem Finale da, da hatten sie schon, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Milliarden – nicht Milliarden, Millionen – Erwähnungen und waren mit Abstand der meistgenannteste Sponsor der Europameisterschaft in den sozialen Medien. Ist ja natürlich klar. Aber sie haben alle großen, super Sponsoren, die man da kennt, gab es nun Bankenversicherungen, Bierkonzerne oder sonst was sind, haben sie mit weitem Abstand geschlagen. Also ein Riesenerfolg. Die Stadt Paris wertet es auch als Erfolg, weil sie haben nämlich nichts dafür bezahlt für die technische Umsetzung. Die Fans haben sich gefreut, weil es ein tolles Ereignis war und wenn man da gerade mal die eigene Fahne gesehen hat. Aber im Endeffekt ist das auch einfach ganz geschicktes Marketing.
Ja, definitiv.
So, mal als kleine Geschichte am Rand.
Da ist ja sowieso die UEFA sehr stark drin. Es gibt Bannmeilen, die sich in verschiedenen Kilometergraden um die Stadien ziehen. Ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass fünf Kilometer rund um ein Stadion herum keine anderen, keine fremden Sponsoren mehr auftauchen dürfen in Sponsoren, also in Sponsorenart. Also ich glaube, eine Mercedes-Benz Filiale wird dann jetzt nicht dichtgemacht und umgebrandet. Aber es dürfte da eben keine Aktion stattfinden. Wie ist denn das, wenn man sich in diesem vollkommen auf diese paar UEFA-Sponsoren reingewaschenen Bereich bewegt, Tobi? Nimmt man das überhaupt noch wahr? Fährt einem auf, dass man da das immer selbe Bier trinkt? Hatte das Bier überhaupt Alkohol in sich?
Ich habe tatsächlich drei oder vier Bier bei elf Spielen im Stadion getrunken. Wir können den Sponsor ja sagen. Das ist Karlsberg. Und Karlsberg hat im Stadion 0, 5% Alkohol im Bier. Also ein Zehntel von dem, was ein normales Bier hat. Zum Betrinken, wenn das Spiel schlecht ist, absolut ungeeignet. Es schmeckte leider auch absolut ungeeignet. Das war überhaupt nicht mein Geschmack. Ich bin Gott sei Dank relativ schnell auf. Und jetzt muss ich gestehen, ich weiß nicht, Turtle Twist, Turtle Twist, Tuchtel Twist, keine Ahnung, wie das Ding heißt. Das kostete dann, da sind wir natürlich auch beim Preis, also so ein Karlsberg kostet im Stadion, je nachdem, wurde bis zwischen 6, 50 und 7 Euro. Das war so die Preis-Bande, die ich erlebt habe. Schmeckte dann, wie eben beschrieben, ein halber Liter in einem durchschnittlich attraktiven Becher, der ohne Pfand war, also man kriegt dann nicht noch einen Euro zurück. Und ich bin dann auf dieses Turtle Twist oder wie auch immer es heißt, gestoßen. Das ist ein All-Star, also Bier mit Brause oder wie heißt es im südlichen Raum? Ah, Radler. Ein Radler, aber mit alkoholfreiem Bier, also das hatte dann nicht 0, 5% Alkohol, sondern 0, 0%, schmeckte aber relativ gut. Also ich hab's dann irgendwann auch im Supermarkt gefunden und da schmeckt es aus der Dose eigentlich auch ganz nett. Ist ein Erfrischungsgetränk letzten Endes. Es hat mit Bier relativ wenig am Hut. Das ist ja bei All-Star und Radler leider immer so, aber man konnte es eigentlich ganz gut trinken, wenn man jetzt nicht eine Cola oder ein Wasser haben wollte. Von daher, für 5 Euro im Stadion, jetzt nicht die schlechteste Alternative. Und ich muss sagen, Wasser, Cola und die ganzen anderen Sachen da, Fanta und sowas, 4 Euro im Stadion, bei der EM, fand ich jetzt persönlich nicht so schlimm. Ist ein fairer Preis in meinen Augen. Also das kriegst du wahrscheinlich in fast kein Bundesligastadion für den Kurs. Zumal die Becher halt umsonst waren und man musste sie auch nicht zurückbringen. Man konnte sie dann in irgendwelche Sammelbehälter geben und solche Geschichten. Das war, ich muss sagen, relativ überraschend positiv. Essen war sehr vielfältig. Also nicht im Sinne von in einem Stadion gab es verschiedene Sachen, sondern wo du warst, also in Bordeaux gab es Pizza, im Stadion, im Karton, das fand ich ganz nett. Wirklich so, du hast dann halt den, wie als wenn der Lieferdienst es dir gebracht hat, hast du dann mit einer einen Platz genommen.
Was war auf dem Pizza-Karton drauf? War der auch gebrandet mit dem Spiel und dem Flak?
Wir haben keine Pizza gegessen. Ich kann es dir ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen, was drauf war.
Das wäre ja mein Mitbringsel geworden, wenn da irgendwas drauf gestanden hätte vom Spiel. Das finde ich sehr zentral.
Ich glaube, es war nicht gebrandet. Also wie gesagt, ich kann es leider nicht sagen. Ich habe einen Hotdog. Wir sind ja dann natürlich auch nicht ganz doof und wissen, wann es in den Stadion geht. Und dann isst ihr halt vorher was, weil wer mag schon das, was es im Stadion gibt. Also es gab in Liora die Pommes roh. Die Pommes habe ich gar nicht gegessen. Ich habe, glaube ich, einmal oder zweimal so einen Hotdog und einmal so einen Sandwich gegessen, weil der Hunger einfach unfassbar groß war. Die Sandwiches sind halt so wie die Sandwiches an den Rastplätzen oder wo auch immer. Die liegen da seit – na ja – nicht erst seit fünf Minuten in der Regel und sind halt kalt. Da ist dann Schinken und Käse oder was auch immer drauf. Und die Hotdogs liegen da wahrscheinlich auch nicht erst seit fünf Minuten. Es ist halt kein kulinarischer Ruhm.
Essen mit Geschichte.
Du isst es halt, damit du satt bist und damit du vielleicht nach dem Spiel noch in Ruhe ein Bier trinken kannst, was nicht direkt ins Blut geht oder so, sondern sich erst mal mit dem Essen noch ein bisschen arrangieren kann. Ich esse halt auch in Bundesligastadien und so. Das war jetzt nicht besser oder schlechter, fand ich. Also die Pizza war wirklich mal ein Highlight, aber das durchschnittliche Bundesligastadion hat ungefähr das gleiche Niveau wie so ein EM-Stadion. Ansonsten muss ich sagen, wenn du raus bist aus dem Stadion, mir fällt da jetzt immer als erstes Bassey ein, weil das Stadion relativ gut in der Innenstadt liegt, im Gegensatz jetzt zu Saint-Denis oder zu Lille oder auch zu Lyon.
Lyon ist ja der absolut weiteste Weg für mich.
Lyon sind schlanke 13 Kilometer draußen. Absolut furchtbar. Und damit ist der absolute Wahnsinn da draußen. Da gibt es halt auch nichts. Aber in Marseille zum Beispiel, von unserem Hotel, das waren so anderthalb Kilometer, eine Straße geradeaus zum Stadion auf der linken und rechten Seite, da gab es Restaurants und Bier und die haben natürlich dann auch direkt an die Straße verkauft, die haben ihre Fässer dahingestellt, zwei rechts und links in den Stuhl und da drüber noch ein Tresen oder so und haben dann für, je nachdem, wie nah man im Stadion war, irgendwas zwischen fünf und acht Euro, haben sie dann in einem halben Liter Bier an der Straße verkauft. Also das war gar nicht so UEFA reglementiert, wie ich es erwartet hätte. Das war dann tatsächlich immer nur direkt im Stadionbereich, da gab es dann Probleme. Oder wie halt in Lyon zum Beispiel, wo du 13 Kilometer außerhalb bist, da gibt es dann halt nichts. Da wartest du, bis du im Stadion bist und dann kannst du da die eben angesprochenen, leckeren 0, 5 Kalsberg trinken.
Und wie war das jetzt mit jenen Sponsoren, die jetzt nicht für Essen und Trinken zuständig waren? Also, Matthias hat es ja schon angesprochen, unter anderem Sokka. Gut, dass du den Namen nochmal gesagt hast. Den Namen hätte ich nämlich schon nicht mehr mir in Erinnerung rufen können. Vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht. Ich wusste aber noch, Aserbaidschanisches Energieunternehmen staatlich geführt. Das heißt, der Staat gibt da mal wieder Geld aus, wo er an anderer Stelle auch vorgibt, keines zu haben. Und man muss sich nicht lange erkundigen, um herauszufinden, mit welcher Art Staat man es bei Aserbaidschan zu tun hat. Also das kann man sehr, sehr kritisch sehen. Und es gibt dann natürlich auch die Frage, die sich stellt. Moment mal, ein aserbaidschanischer Energiekonzern staatlich geführt. Warum geben die überhaupt so viel Geld aus? Ich glaube, ich habe sogar bei euch Matthias einen Beitrag gehört, von dem ich glaube, 94 Millionen Euro hatte ich abgespeichert. Oder vielleicht waren es sogar – nee, jetzt will ich keine falsche Zahl nennen. Also auf jeden Fall ein hoher Betrag. Haben die denn auch vor Ort etwas getan, um den Zuschauern im Gedächtnis zu bleiben? Oder kann man vielleicht sagen, dadurch, dass die nur über Bande aktiviert haben, dass das vielleicht eher so ein Ding war, um im europäischen Markt ein bisschen bekannter zu werden und vielleicht eher auch Touröffner bei einigen Entscheider-Positionen. Und es ging da gar nicht jetzt darum, irgendwie den Fans klarzumachen, dass es da ein ganz tolles Energieunternehmen gibt.
Also ist mir jetzt nicht untergekommen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es Tobi geht. Also da ist mir jetzt nicht irgendwie offensive Werbung untergekommen. Aber das war ja auf den Banden schon relativ deutlich zu sehen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es auf Fernsehbildern war im Stadion. War es absolut, kam man gar nicht dran vorbei, weil die auch noch, ich glaube, schwarz war die Bande ja. Also absolut prominent zu sehen. Und ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich eine Art Türöffner und der Wegbereiter für 2020, wenn wir dann in Baku die Spiele haben. Das ist schon, glaube ich, jetzt ein Schritt einfach gewesen, die weiteren Folgen dann.
Muss ich mich anschließen? Also ich habe auch unabhängig, ja, abgesehen von diesen Essen-Trinken-Geschichten, auch rund um Stadion, weiß nicht, wenn man sich da jetzt vorstellt, da gibt es einen, weiß ich nicht, einen, wer ist der Autosponsor? Hyundai, Auto oder so, keine Ahnung, was ich dann streicheln kann und ein Foto machen kann, habe ich zumindest nicht wahrgenommen. Vielleicht bin ich da auch schon so abgestumpft, dass ich einfach dran vorbeilaufe und es mir egal ist. Auf den Fan-Milen gab es irgendwie so eine Foto-Boxen, ich glaube mit Coca Cola oder so, wo man dann irgendwelche tollen Fotos machen konnte und auch irgendwelche, wie ja so, so hoher Schuss-Dinger oder dann flog der Ball auf dich zu, du warst der Torwart, ich weiß jetzt aber auch nicht mehr, welcher Sponsor da dahinter steckt. Also da gab es auf den Fan-Milen gab es des Öfteren so ein paar Geschichten, wo ich gedacht habe, okay, das ist jetzt ganz klar ein Sponsor zuzuordnen, der hier irgendeine Geschichte verkaufen will und dann wahrscheinlich, wenn du das gespielt hast oder mitgemacht hast, drückt er dir noch den Flyer in der Hand, damit du dir dann das Auto oder was auch immer noch angucken kannst. Aber im Stadion selber, ich glaube, da galt vielleicht einfach wirklich nicht noch mehr Probleme ins Leben rufen als nötig und jeden, den wir hier reinlassen, den müssen wir kontrollieren und das ist Arbeit und das ist unnötig. Da wurde halt Essen, Trinken verkauft, aber danach hört es zumindest, was meine Wahrnehmung aktuell angeht, komplett auf.
Ich glaube, um mal auf Zucker zurückzukommen, die haben, glaube ich, einen der Preise gesponsort. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt der Jugendspieler des Turniers war, also irgendwie für irgendeinen Preis sind die da noch als Sponsor quasi…
Das müsste ja dann die Leuchte des Turniers gewesen sein eigentlich.
Ja, irgendwie sowas. Aber am meisten zu sehen, tatsächlich hat sie gerade angesprochen, Orange, der Telefonkonzern, der Französische, die haben ja auch noch bei jedem Spiel den Fan of the Match gekürt. Ich weiß nicht nach welchen Regeln die den ausgewählt haben. Auf einmal prangte irgendwie so ein Foto von einem Fan, der nicht mal im Stadion sein musste und der war dann der Fan of the Match. Also die waren für…
Und da haben wir den Matthias kurz mal verloren.
Dann können wir vielleicht noch ganz kurz die McDonalds-Fußball-Exkorte oder wie die hießen einwerfen. Die scheint ja in Deutschland ganz große Nummer zum Finale gewesen zu sein, weil da ja ein deutsches Kind, ich weiß gar nicht, ob Mädchen oder Junge, mitgelaufen ist. Habe ich natürlich nicht mitgekriegt vor Ort, aber in Deutschland scheint das ja ein ganz dickes Ding gewesen zu sein.
Ja, es gab nicht so viel, über das man berichten konnte und dann konnte man sich freuen, mein Gott, wir hatten einen Einlaufkind oder Auflaufkind.
Ich glaube, Auflauf ist falsch. Wie auch immer, aber Auflauf müsste falsch sein.
Was mich ja noch interessieren würde, wie sehr geht einem der Countdown auf den Nerv oder feiert man das eher, weil man ja tatsächlich auch selbst die ganze Zeit aufs Spiel hin fiebert. Also ich meine, den Countdown, der zum Amt für Finn heruntergezählt wurde.
Ging mir gar nicht so auf die Nerven. War tatsächlich für mich mehr so eine Erinnerung, mal ganz kurz das Handy rauszuholen. Es gibt gleich einen Anstoß. Du kannst ein schönes Foto machen. Mitgeschrien habe ich ihn, glaube ich, auch nicht. Also, nee. Ich war immer relativ nüchtern und relativ beieinander, als ich in den Stadien war. Deshalb, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass ich da irgendwie mitgegrölt habe und von 10 auf 0 runtergezählt habe. Er ist ja, Herrgott, vielleicht braucht man es einfach. Also, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht freut sich auch der Typ in der Regie, dass er sagt, oh, jetzt weiß ich, jetzt muss ich wieder aufpassen oder so. Was sollen sie machen? Ich bin da wirklich schmerzfrei, was solche Geschichten angeht.
Hat beim ZDF fast geklappt beim Halbfinale.
Ja, das habe ich auch gehört, dass das irgendwie nicht so ganz funktioniert hat.
Nee, nicht so ganz.
Insgesamt weiß ich nicht. Dann sollen sie halt so einen Counter machen. Solange sie mit zehn Sekunden auf den Sack gehen, ist es doch relativ harmlos oder nicht?
Ja, nö. War eine ergebnisoffene Frage. Matthias, du bist uns kurz verloren gegangen. Was wolltest du noch loswerden?
Ich bin, weiß ich gar nicht, bin ich im Satz zusammengebrochen. Mitten im Satz. Ich war glaube ich bei Orange, oder?
Genau.
Ich wollte nur sagen, die waren für mich die präsentesten mit ihrer Farbe, weil sie ja allein wegen der orangenen Farbe und dann mit dem Fan of the Match, der ja nicht mal im Stadion war, unbedingt, wo ich nicht gar nicht weiß, nach welchen Kriterien der ausgewählt wurde. Also die waren für mich einer der präsentesten Sponsoren dieser Europameisterschaft.
So, dann würde mich jetzt noch interessieren, mal so ein bisschen auf die einzelnen Nationen einzugehen, die da waren. Da fällt mir zuerst ein, dass ja jede Nation ihren eigenen Stadionsprecher oder Stadionsprecherin mitbringen durfte. Die Spanierin habe ich persönlich noch in eigener Erinnerung. Die hat mich so ein bisschen an den Vorsänger bei den Eintracht Frankfurt Ultras erinnert, ehrlich gesagt. Tobi, wer war denn da der angenehmste und der schlimmste Vertreter, den du live erlebt hast?
Boah, manchmal gibt es Fragen, wo ich denke, Max, das hätte sie mir mal vor sagen können. Da muss ich mich doch darauf vorbereiten. Nee, keine Ahnung. Krieg ich nicht.
Dann hast du keine prägende Erinnerung.
Ja, genau. Ich erinnere mich natürlich daran, dass der Deutsche Deutsch gesprochen hat und dass der dann auch dieses schwarze Weiß angekündigt hat von Oliver Pocher, was gar nicht mehr Oliver Pocher gesungen hat, wenn mich nicht alles getäuscht hat im Stadion. Da gibt es scheinbar eine neue Version. Aber nee, da gab es jetzt eigentlich keinen, der besonders positiv oder besonders negativ aufgefallen ist bei den Stadionsprechern.
Matthias, hast du da jemanden oder ist das vielleicht…
Ich erinnere mich vor allen Dingen dran, dass ich gar nicht das Gefühl hatte, dass von jedem einer da war. Also bei manchen Spielen hatte ich das Gefühl, da ist nur von einem Land irgendwie einer da. Oder vielleicht habe ich mich auch total verguckt, aber das ist meine Erinnerung. Und ich erinnere mich daran, dass der, der am einundig präsentesten war von seinem Auftreten bei den Spielen, die ich gesehen habe, der österreichische war, der richtig da Party gemacht hat und richtig die Fans angeheizt hat. Und auch diese, ich sage mal, eher geschäftsmäßigen Zwischenkommentare, also in der 78. Minute hat die österreichische Mannschaft ausgewechselt, das ist ausgeschieden, bla bla bla, dass er das dann, ging ja auch um einiges für Österreich, dass er das noch versucht hat, mit Anfeuerungen zu verhindern. Also jetzt geht's nochmal und jetzt zeigt er mal, was er könnte und zehn Minuten. Und also der ist mir in Erinnerung geblieben, weil der halt da seine Show gemacht hat und seine, seine Anheizungsmethoden angewendet hat und nicht nur dem klassischen Sprech da verfallen ist.
Es ist ausgeschieden, ja, dann letztlich komplett Österreich. Und wie war es jetzt bei den Fans? Wir haben auch hier in Deutschland viel natürlich über die irischen Fans mitbekommen, nordirische Fans, über die valisischen Fans. Es kreist sich schon ein über die isländischen Fans. Was mich jetzt mal interessieren würde, vor allem, weil wir mit Tobi jemanden dabei haben, der bei fünf deutschen Spielen war. Wie sind denn die deutschen Fans so organisiert und sagen es technisch unterwegs? Bei mir am Fernsehen kamen nur an, die Nummer eins der Welt sind wir. Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland. Sieg, Sieg, Sieg. Mexiko von den Onkels.
Und scheiß Italiener.
Genau und scheiß Italiener. Erdeckt sich der Eindruck mit dem von vor Ort, dass die deutschen Fans nicht so wirklich organisiert sind und auch nicht so wirkliches Liedgut haben, was gesungen wird.
Wer nicht hüpft, ist kein Deutscher oder irgendwie so in der Richtung. Das gab es auch noch. Aber dann wird es bei mir echt dünn, mit den Ideen, was da noch gab. Die Sieggeschichte, natürlich zu Recht, oft kritisiert.
Ist es im Stadion auch so? Also am Fernseher kriege ich tatsächlich manchmal im Negativen eine Gänsehaut. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine Sensibilität ist, die vielleicht auch so ein bisschen zu einer Political Correctness entspricht. Ist das vor Ort tatsächlich auch so oder empfindet man das vielleicht gar nicht so, wenn auch drum herum andere Dinge geschrien werden?
Genau. Das ist es eben. Also am Fernsehen weißt du ja nicht, wie viele Prozent der Leute es tatsächlich singen. Da sind wir wieder bei, ich hatte viele Spiele an Plätzen, wo es halt neutrale Bereiche sind. Da hast du natürlich gerade mit Deutschland gespielt, zum Beispiel im achten Finale gegen die Slowakei. Da waren ja die neutralen Bereiche wahrscheinlich zu 60, 70 Prozent mit deutschen Fans. Aber da hast du vielleicht einfach ein bisschen andere Fans und da sang das halt keiner. Also da hat halt auch keiner von der Nummer eins der Welt gesungen und da hat auch keiner das Sieg laut mitgeschrieben, was ich insgesamt erfrischend selten gehört habe. Also wir haben es gehört und natürlich hat man es auch am Fernsehen gehört, aber ich fand, es kam relativ selten, was vielleicht auch einfach daran lag, dass wir gar nicht so viele Spiele gewonnen haben. Ich muss sagen, es ist wenig Kreativität da. Es sind wenig verschiedene Sachen werden gesungen. Ich saß wie gesagt nur einmal mitten im Fanblog. Da war es auch so, was die Leute anging, so ein bisschen unangenehm. Die Polen haben, als wir das Vorrundenspiel in die Polen hatten, im Sontenis 0-0 gespielt und auf einmal fingen die Polen auf Deutsch an zu singen, Auf Wiedersehen Deutschland. Also man hörte es wirklich in diesem großen Stadion auf der anderen Seite, Deutschland auf Wiedersehen, Deutschland auf Wiedersehen in deutscher Sprache. Da haben sich doch schon einige Leute arg daneben benommen auf der deutschen Seite. Also das war sehr, sehr unangenehm, die ganze Geschichte. Aber das dritte Vorrundspiel habe ich nicht gesehen. Und dann ab Achtelfinale hatte ich das Gefühl, wurde jetzt unabhängig von den Deutschen auf alle Mannschaften bezogen, dass das Fan-Klientel einfach viel, viel sympathischer. Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt, dass man das vielleicht dann einfach nicht so gut planen konnte oder so. Aber sowohl in der Stadt als auch in den Stadien, die Leute wurden im Schnitt netter, sympathischer. Es wurde mehr gelächelt und nicht für viel böse geguckt. Es wurde weniger rumgebrüllt. Es wurde sich weniger daneben benommen. Das war so eine allgemeine Beobachtung, die ich hatte, quasi ab Achtelfinale. Das deckt sich ja letzten Endes dann auch mit den Ausschreitungen, die es dann quasi gar nicht mehr gab. Das sind ein, zwei Pyro-Geschichten, die gezündet wurden. Aber insgesamt so die Vorrunde, die vier Spiele, die ich gesehen habe, die zwei Deutschlandspiele, das waren nicht immer ganz nett und nicht ganz entspannt. Da waren halt auch echt ein paar komische Leute mit dabei. Aber Irland-Schweden hat es natürlich rausgerissen. Und Rumänien-Schweiz war auch soweit ganz nett.
Ich wollte es gerade sagen. Irland-Schweden. Absolutes Highlight, was die Stimmung angeht. Ich war zufällig im Stadion und ich hatte das Glück, mit einer, ja, man könnte fast sagen Party-Metro zu fahren, genau zwischen einer irischen Sangesgruppe und einer schwedischen Sangesgruppe, die sich gegenseitig hochgesungen haben, schon auf der Metrostation. Es hat irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen länger gedauert, als deine Bahn kam und die haben sich da schon auf dem Bahnsteig warmgesungen mit ihren klassischen Liedern und die haben dann auch gegeneinander und übereinander und miteinander gesungen. Und ich habe manchmal gedacht, das wäre vielleicht mit anderen Fans von anderen Nationen anders ausgegangen. Also die Iren haben immer eher Stand-Up for the Boys in Green gesungen, was man ja auch gehört hat am Fernseher. Und dann haben die Schweden zum Teil, ich sage mal jetzt, diplomatisch und freundlich ausgedrückt, mit Augenzwinkern zurückgesungen, Go Home to Your Ugly Wives. Das hätte auch anders ausgehen können. Die Iren haben einfach gesungen und haben einfach mitgemacht und haben Party draus gemacht und haben gesagt, okay, dann singt das halt und jetzt machen wir hier Spaß mit euch und stoßen gleich zusammen an und haben einfach ein geiles Spiel. Das hätte bei anderen – das ist eine Unterstellung von mir – aber das hätte auch bei anderen Fangruppen durchaus anders ausgehen können.
Ganz auf jeden Fall. Also dieses Irland-Schwedenspiel war ein Musterbeispiel von Harmonie und Kuschelkurs. Wir waren nur vorm Stadion, da wir mit dem Taxi zu dem Spiel gefahren, haben dann vorm Stadion noch eine Stunde oder so gestanden und es war einfach alles gemischt. Also es waren die grünen Iren und die blau-gelben Schweden. Es war nur gemischt. Die Polizei hat sich nirgends eingemischt. Es haben alle Bier miteinander getrunken. Es waren alle chillig. Es haben alle miteinander geredet. Dazwischen, wie immer, viele deutsche Fans. Auch die verdammt gut integriert, sag ich mal, in diese ganze Geschichte mit rein. Es war wirklich ein absolutes Highlight. Es war, glaube ich, noch der erste Spieltag gegen Schweden und war sehr, sehr positiv, gerade im Vergleich zu diesen anderen Geschichten, die dann da in Marseille passiert sind, England gegen Russland und so. Es war wirklich ein Highlight der ganzen Reise, diese beiden Länder zu sehen.
Und vor allen Dingen im Stadion auch die neutralen Blöcke, die gab es ja gar nicht in der Form, weil ja dann gemischt die Trikots da waren. Das Stadion war ja eigentlich komplett gelb oder grün. Es gab ja gar nicht diese bunten blau, weiß, schwarz irgendwie angezogenen Leute, sondern das war entweder grün oder gelb oder gemischt. Das war Wahnsinn, das zu sehen.
Selbst unser neutraler Block, der so ein bisschen – wir saßen mal in Schweden in der Ecke, das war offensichtlich irgendwie so ein improvisierter Block. Da war so eine klapprige Tribüne, da saßen vielleicht 100 Leute drauf. Wir drei aus Deutschland, dazu noch fünf im Deutschland-Trikot und der Rest war halt Hälfte, Hälfte Schweden und Irland. Die haben sich beide nichts geschenkt auf den Tribünen, was die Stimmung anging, haben richtig schön – ging auch 1-1 aus – haben beide richtig schön sich in den richtigen Momenten gefreut. Auch nicht gefiffen, wenn die einen Feiert haben, das waren so Sachen, die in anderen Spielen aufgefallen sind, dass man pfeift als Reaktion auf das Gesinge der gegnerischen Mannschaft total unnötig, anstatt dass man selber was singt. Aber das war bei dem Spiel auch überhaupt nicht der Fall. Es war ein großartiger Ausflug Irland gegen Schweden. Wird auf jeden Fall lange in meiner Erinnerung bleiben.
Auf jeden Fall. Absolut. Auch ein absoluter Stimmungshilheit dieses Spiel und Musterbeispiel für das, wie es sein kann. Sportlich war das Spiel jetzt kein großer Knaller, aber das Drumherum war absolut Weltklasse.
Wen ich noch positiv gerne erwähnen möchte in der ganzen Geschichte sind die Portugiesen. Okay, sie haben es natürlich relativ leicht gehabt, weil es dann irgendwann lief wie geschnitten Brot.
Moment mal, die haben nur einmal nach 90 Minuten gewonnen.
Ich habe sie ja erst gesehen ab Viertelfinale. Ich habe das Viertelfinale der Portugiesen in Polen gesehen, ich habe das Halbfinale gegen Wales gesehen und ich habe das Finale gegen Frankreich gesehen und sie waren bei allen drei Spielen, ich sage mal natürlich, die Mannschaft mit den wenigereren Fans, mit dem kleineren Fan-Block, sowohl die Polen als auch die Waliser als auch die Franzosen hatten deutlich mehrere Fans natürlich dabei. Aber sie haben immer, auch wenn sie nicht geführt haben, haben sie sehr gute Stimmung verbreitet, waren laut, waren gut organisiert. Man konnte das sehen, die hatten da vorne so ein, zwei Karpos, Vorturner, was auch immer stehen, die für die Koordination gesorgt haben, hatten immer ihre große Blockfahne mit dabei und haben wirklich dreimal mich beeindruckt und es hat dreimal Spaß gemacht, in der Nähe der Portugiesen zu sitzen und den Fans zuzugucken, beim Stimmung machen. Schön.
Gibt es noch eine Nation, die euch da in besonderen Erinnerungen bleibt? Matthias, hast du noch vielleicht ein Erlebnis?
Ich war bei Österreich gegen Island, habe ich ja vorhin schon mal erwähnt. Einmal überraschend, wie viele Österreicher da waren und wie das abgelaufen ist, trotz des absolut desolaten Ausscheidens der Mannschaft, die ja relativ hoch gewettet war. Gut, sie haben dann im Endeffekt, muss man ja auch sagen, fast in der Todesgruppe gespielt mit Europameister und Überraschungsteam. Aber wie Island dann gefeiert hat, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so, um nochmal auf die UEFA zurückzukommen. Die sind ja relativ gnadenlos. Da wird der Abpfiff passiert, sagen wir mal, beim 18 Uhr Spiel, 10 vor 8. Um spätestens 5 vor 8, nachdem die Statistiken über die Videowand geflimmert sind und der Spieler des Spiels bekannt gegeben wurde, wird dann gesagt, so, Ausgang Down, da geht es da und hin. Wer zu Fan-Modern will, bitte Ausgang B7 und wer in die Stadt möchte, Ausgang C5 oder wie auch immer. Und da wird dir relativ schnell klar gemacht, okay, hier ist der Spaß vorbei und jetzt geht es nach Hause und dann wird die UEFA-Mucke angedreht, die da von der Playlist kommt und dann das Gefühl der Rausschmeißermusik so ein bisschen. Und die Isländer, die ja gerade einen historischen Erfolg hatten, die haben einfach im strömenden Regen von Saint-Denis eine halbe Stunde nach Abpfiff immer noch mit voller Stärke im Block gestanden und gesungen und die Spieler sind nochmal raus und nochmal in die Kurve und die müssen davon überhaupt nicht beeindrucken lassen und das fand ich echt stark. Man hatte viel über die Isländer geredet, aber das fand ich echt eine starke Aktion nach diesem 2 zu 1 gegen Österreich.
Man kann, wenn man Eindrücke von vor Ort haben möchte und man nicht den Luxus hatte, so wie ihr vor Ort gewesen zu sein, kann ich nur empfehlen im YouTube-Kanal der 11 Freunde gibt es Videos und die 11 Freunde haben dann auch gesagt, es war so ein bisschen die EM der Fans. Und vielleicht kann man das tatsächlich vor allem mit Blick auf das, was da noch so kommt, bestätigt sich das fast schon von alleine. Wir werden eine WM in Russland haben, wo die Anreisewege, die Kosten und das ganze Drumherum etwas komplett anderes sein wird. Dann werden wir eine EM haben, die zwischen Bilbao und Baku ausgespielt wird, in ganz verschiedenen Orten, nicht von einer Nation als Gastgeber organisiert wird. Und dann geht es ja schon nach Katar. Das schreit natürlich auch nach einem Feiern der Fan-Kultur. Wie habt ihr es denn vor Ort empfunden? Tobi, fang du mal an. Hast du auch so das Gefühl gehabt, die Fans waren vielleicht, also sportlich hat man ja gesagt, es war eher mau. Haben das die Fans vielleicht jenseits der Stadien wieder rausgerissen?
Ja, ich habe natürlich vor Ort nicht alles mitgekriegt, aber so das eine oder andere YouTube-Video hat man sich natürlich angeguckt, auch auf dem von dir eben genannten Kanal. Die Fans waren schon positiv, muss ich sagen. Wir haben die Probleme angesprochen, die es da gab, das war in Marseille nicht schön, aber danach beruhigte es sich ja dann wirklich relativ schnell bis auf ein paar Aussetzer innerhalb des Stadions. Spielerisch, wenn man das vergleichen muss, das spielerische mit dem, was auf den Tribünen passiert ist, war es wahrscheinlich tatsächlich das Turnier der Fans. Vielleicht muss man das dann letzten Endes so festhalten und dann sind wir wahrscheinlich auch bei einem Punkt, der diese 24 Mannschaften als positiv darstellen kann, weil vielleicht wäre das eine oder andere Land nicht mit dabei gewesen, was für gute Stimmung gesorgt hat. Vielleicht kann man so versuchen, es sich schön zu reden.
Turnier der Fans in positiver wie negativer Sicht könnte man vielleicht auch noch sagen. Wir hatten ja eigentlich gedacht, dass die Zeiten der Ausschreitungen von Hooligans ein bisschen in der Vergangenheit angehören oder zumindest gehofft, dass es jetzt nochmal so massiv wiederkam, hat sowohl die UEFA überrascht als auch die Sicherheitsbehörden. Also das muss man vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen, wenn man das Bild komplett machen will. Aber klar, Turnier der Fans stimmt schon und was über die kleinen Länder gesagt wird, wie Nordirland, wie Wales. Irgendwie gehört das auch zu diesem 24er-Feld dazu. Vielleicht kleine Randaneckdote zum 24er-Feld, ohne das große Fass jetzt aufmachen zu wollen. Abschlusspressekonferenz, UEFA, zwei Tage vor dem Finale. Warum ist das 24er-Feld ein Erfolg? Weil eine Mannschaft, die in der Weltrangliste ganz vorne dabei ist, wie Holland es nicht mal geschafft hat, zur Europameisterschaft zu kommen und wir so viel Qualität im europäischen Fußball haben. Also weil Holland nicht dabei war, ist das 24er-Feld ein Erfolg. Zitat UEFA.
Ich habe so lange nach diesem O-Ton gesucht, Matthias. Irgendwann war ich auf, ich glaube, ein russischer, ich glaube, es war ein russischer YouTube-Kanal, der so zum Teil diese Pressekonferenz in Ausschnitten hatte. Und ich habe ihn nicht gefunden, weil ich das so, ich hatte das auch gelesen bei dir auch auf Twitter und ich fand dieses Zitat so unfassbar.
Wenn ich es finde, dann werde ich es nochmal, werde ich es nochmal weiterverbreiten.
Ja, generell hat sich die UEFA, UEFA fand mal wieder alles super, was gelaufen ist. Vielleicht können wir das nochmal ganz kurz thematisieren, denn das finde ich schon interessant. Du hast es vollkommen richtigerweise nochmal eingeordnet mit dem Turnier der Fans. Es gab eben auch die Negativseite. Und gleichzeitig hatten wir jetzt auch einige Dinge im Stadion, da lässt sich nicht alles verhindern, haben wir darüber gesprochen, aber es stellen sich auch einige Fragen. Danke für's Zuhören!
Ertäuscht dieser Eindruck, Matthias? An zwei Stellen kann man glaube ich so eine Art immerhin sagen, da ist, an zwei Stellen war die UEFA immerhin selbstkritisch, das gilt einmal für den Modus 24 Mannschaften, da haben sie gesagt, ja, wir haben Fehler gemacht, haben sie so zugegeben, oder es ist nicht alles so perfekt rund gelaufen, es könnte besser laufen, da ging es darum, ich weiß nicht, wie sie es jetzt verbessern wollen, aber da ging es darum, dass es ja diese vielen spielfreien Tage rund ums Achtelfinale gab, die man halt einfach braucht, weil nicht klar war, welcher Gruppen dritte nun weiterkommt und wer gegen wen und dann muss man ja auch noch die Logistik vorbereiten, dass die Mannschaften Zeit haben, sich vorzubereiten und dahin zu fahren und was alles so dran hängt, das war der eine Punkt und das zweite immerhin, man hat sich flexibler gezeigt, was die Anstoßzeiten angeht, das ist, glaube ich, nur ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein, aber sie haben sich immerhin bereit erklärt für die nächsten Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich in den nächsten Turniere bei Risikospielen auch kurzfristig die Anstoßzeiten zu verändern und Duellen wie England gegen Russland dann auf 15 Uhr und nicht auf 21 Uhr zu schieben, weil man eben da den Alkohol als den größten Feind des Friedens ausgemacht hat, was ja irgendwie auch ein bisschen fadenscheinig ist, weil man hat das Problem definitiv einfach unterschätzt, auch als UEFA. Aber immerhin ist man da mal abgerückt von dieser es war alles super und wir haben uns gar nicht zur Schulden kommen lassen Linie, das ist vielleicht nur ein kleines bisschen, aber immerhin ist man da so weit gegangen. Ansonsten war das ein absolutes Feiern der UEFA, ein absolutes Feiern des Turniers. Da wurden, es war so eine kleine Powerpoint-Präsentation zu den Reden, da wurden also nur die Superlative präsentiert. Man hat sich gefeiert für die Einnahmen, wir haben am meisten Geld verdient seit Rekord und die TV-Quoten, da wurde sich für gefeiert, bis hin zur Zahl, dass beim isländischen Spiel nur 298 Isländer nicht zugeguckt haben, wurde so von der UEFA verkündet, bis hin natürlich und das Thema gehört irgendwie fürs Bild der Europameisterschaft auch dazu, dass bei dieser Pressekonferenz der Name Platini unglaublich oft gefallen ist. Wir wissen ja, gesperrt, verbannt vom Fußball wegen seiner Korruptionsgeschäfte und schon in der Eröffnungsansprache vom amtierenden Präsidenten Via Iona, der ja ihn ja vertritt. Der hat im Prinzip eine zehnminütige Rede gehalten. Davon waren acht Minuten Danksagungen. Er hat seine Rede angefangen mit dem Satz, wer nicht dankbar ist, der also, der macht das falsch. Dankbarkeit ist ein hohes Gut. Wir müssen dankbar sein. Und eine ewig lange Litanei von Danksagungen losgelassen. Ist auch, glaube ich, okay. Aber dann kam nicht mehr viel Substantielles und dann kamen noch so Sätze wie, wir sind in Gedanken bei Michel Platini. Er kann stolz auf seine EM sein. Und dann gipfelte das ja dann auch nach dem Finale in diesem Bild auf der Videowand. Danke für alles, Michel. Also da ist die UEFA ein bisschen selbstgerecht und hat wieder die Scheuklappen auf mit den kleinen Immerhinns, die ich da ja hinzufügen wollte gerade.
Da gab es auch ein ordentliches Pfeifkonzert für nach dem Finale, für das von dir eben angesprochene Bildchen von Platini und den Danksagungen. Da war wirklich viel, viel Pfeifen im noch gut gefüllten, weiten Rund.
Ja, da bin ich sehr gespannt auf die Langzeitfolgen dieser Europameisterschaft und vielleicht muss man das dann das nächste Turnier noch mit reinnehmen. Wird jetzt immer häufiger thematisiert die Überreizung sowohl der Spieler als auch der Zuschauer. Ich denke, da kommen dann auch so Themen, wie wir vorhin schon besprochen haben, dann vielleicht auch noch mal mit rein, die zwar auch alle lokal begründet sein wollen, wegen zum Beispiel Ticket-Nachfrage usw. Aber ich bin mal gespannt, wie es sich da weiterentwickelt, wie wir vielleicht dann über die nächsten zwei Turniere sprechen werden in der Retrospektive. Da verändert sich so ein bisschen was. Jetzt haben wir schon ganz lange über die EM gesprochen. Gibt es denn noch so einzelne Erlebnisse, die euch mit begleiten werden, auch vielleicht, wenn ihr euch noch ein Jahr dran erinnert? Tobi, fang mal an.
Mein Auto.
Stimmt, das haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen. Du bist mit dem Auto gefahren.
Ich bin mit dem Auto gefahren, ja. Insgesamt waren es dann in dieser zweiten Tour, also die erste Tour, da bin ich nur auf einem Beifahrersitz gesessen. Das hat mir dann auch gereicht. Das waren irgendwie 1600 Kilometer. Und die zweite Tour waren dann 5200 Kilometer durch Frankreich. Man zahlt ja Maut in Frankreich, aber das hat nicht nur seine Nachteile. Klar, das kostet Geld, aber es hat auch viele, viele Vorteile. Du kannst wirklich ein ganz entspanntes Auto fahren haben. Du darfst maximal 130 kmh fahren, das heißt, alles pendelt sich so bei 140 auf den Tacho ein, also so um 130 in der Realität. Und du kannst ja teilweise einfach 100 Kilometer am Stück fahren und es nicht überholt keiner und du musst keinen überholen, weil alle fahren die gleiche Geschwindigkeit und es ist total chillig und sehr angenehm und es war wirklich fast ein kleiner Kulturschock, als ich dann am Montag nach dem Finale über die, ich glaube, belgisch-deutsche Grenze Wars gefahren bin. Auf einmal konnte jeder wieder so schnell fahren, wie er möchte und du fährst halt 100, weiß ich nicht, 50 auf der linken Spur und auf einmal kommt einer von hinten angeflogen und ballert dich da aus der linken Spur. Also das waren so Sachen, die passieren hier in Frankreich einfach nicht. Da ist Autobahn nicht immer gleich, ich habe den schnellsten und den größten und wir müssen so viel hier lang kacheln, sondern das ist einfach entspanntes Autofahren und das war so insgesamt meine Eindruck eigentlich fast vom ganzen Land, trotz aller Terrorgeschichten, trotz Polizeipräsenz und so. Die Leute lassen sich wenig aus der Ruhe bringen. Es war sehr angenehm. Ich war ja auch nicht nur immer in den Spielorten. Ich habe es vorhin angesprochen in Clermont-Ferrand, noch mal am Mittelmeer, an einem Ort, wo kein Fußball war und dann noch mal auf dem Weg zum Finale. Wir waren auch in so einem kleinen Nest. Ich habe den Namen glatt vergessen. Auch da und auch in den Spielorten irgendwie, es gibt so diese Lässigkeit und diese Entspanntheit. Es war insgesamt eine sehr, sehr schöne Erfahrung und sehr, sehr viele nette und ruhige, freundliche Menschen getroffen. Auch dieses Vorurteil, wenn du kein Französisch sprichst und ich spreche tatsächlich so gut wie gar nicht Französisch, dann kommst du da auch überhaupt nicht weit. Nein, es ist das Gegenteil gewesen. Die meisten haben es wirklich versucht mit Händen und Füßen ein bisschen Englisch, ein bisschen Französisch und vielen Wiederholungen. Man konnte wirklich, ja, es war eine schöne Zeit in dem Land und es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, dort durch die Gegend zu reisen und ich glaube insgesamt habe ich neun verschiedene Städte gesehen. Das war es wert, war wirklich toll.
Das ist schön zu sehen, auch wenn ich es ein bisschen ironisch finde, dass ich dich nach deinem EM-Erlebnis frage und du antwortest mit der Autobahn.
Wir haben so viel über Fußball gesprochen, dann gab es natürlich ganz viele schöne Spiele. Vollkommen okay.
Und was nimmst du jetzt von dieser EM mit? Du warst ja noch ein bisschen in anderer Funktion dort unterwegs.
Das sind glaube ich eher die kleinen Geschichten, die mir dann hängen bleiben. Ich habe ganz am Anfang den portugiesischen Kollegen angesprochen, den wir gehört haben, auch João Patero. Das sind so die Geschichten, die mir hängen bleiben. Vielleicht noch eine ganz kleine Geschichte, weil wir schon auch ganz viele der Anekdoten, die mir jetzt noch so präsent sind, ja angesprochen haben, was aus den Stadien passiert ist und was so rundum für Geschichten waren. Eine Geschichte, die auch sehr interessant war, ich war mehrfach in der Nähe von Paris im Norden, in Chantilly. Das ist ein kleines, ferdeverrücktes Städtchen. Das war das Hauptquartier der Engländer. Und da war ich drei Mal insgesamt zur Pressekonferenz und zwar an den Tagen vor dem Brexit-Referendum und nach dem Brexit-Referendum, weil ich einfach Hintergrundbeiträge machen wollte, wie geht jetzt die englische Mannschaft damit um und was heißt das eigentlich jetzt. Hab da bei der Pressekonferenz natürlich mitgeschnitten, da war nicht so viel zu bekommen. Hab dann auch mich mit Kollegen unterhalten, die mir dann noch so ein paar Sachen, so ein paar Sichtweisen der englischen Seite erzählt haben, auch was die Premier League angeht. Das war sehr spannend und dann war ich noch einmal ein drittes Mal da und zwar an dem Tag nach dem Ausscheiden gegen Island, wo dann Roy Hodgson, obwohl er nicht kommen wollte, weil er ja schon zurückgetreten, dann doch noch erschienen ist. Und eine kleine journalistische Beobachtung an dieser Seite von den Kollegen, also das war alles sehr relaxed von den englischen Seiten die ganze Zeit, total entspannt. Die saßen da in gemütlicher Kleidung, also ich will auch kein diffamieren oder so, ist auch alles völlig in Ordnung. Es war sehr warm in Chantilly und die Fragen, die da gestellt wurden vor dem Viertelfinale gegen Island, waren so ein bisschen, ja, habt ihr Angst Elfmeter zu schießen? Also so, man kann sich das vorstellen. Es war alles eher friedlich, freundlich und das läuft auch ein bisschen anders ab als bei die FB-Pressekonferenzen, die jemand zum Teil auch live gucken konnte. Also da wird das Mikrofon rumgereicht bei den bei den Granten, sagen wir mal, BBC, Sky, Telegraph, Times und dann darf jeder Journalist, der da vorne in ersten Reisen jetzt erstmal so viele Fragen stellen, wie er will, dann wird es rumgereicht und dann wird irgendwann gefragt, hat noch jemand Fragen? Dann kommt vielleicht noch ein, zwei von ausländischen Kollegen und dann wird sofort gesagt, okay, keine Fragen mehr, tschüss und dann ist die Pressekonferenz nach sechs Minuten vorbei. Das war die ganze Zeit so und ich war immer bei Wayne Rooney da und einmal bei Harry Kane. Da kam auch einfach nicht viel, muss man auch mal fairerweise sagen, von den Kollegen oder von den Spielern. Dann der Tag nach dem Ausscheiden gegen Island, gleiche Setting, gleiches Konferenzzentrum, gleiche Journalisten, alle Kollegen wiedergetroffen, die man vorher da gesehen hat. Auf einmal völlig andere Stimmung, kein Poloshirt mehr, Anzug und Krawatte, keine Frage mehr nach irgendwelchen Elfmetern. Da wurden andere Fragen aufgezogen. Man hatte das Gefühl, wir sind gerade Teil eines staatstragenden Aktes. Die englische Journal hier befragt, Roy Hodgson, nach seinem Aus. Und der hat nichts weiter gesagt, als die ganze Zeit, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich hier bin. Was soll ich hier? Ich habe ein Statement abgegeben, ich bin nicht mehr Trainer und so weiter. Das hat dann auch nicht nur sechs Minuten gedauert, sondern 25 diese Pressekonferenz. Und dann wurden auch mal andere Fragen aufgezogen, die die mir am meisten in Erinnerung ist von einem Kollegen von der BBC. Der hat gefragt, Roy Hodgson, lieber Roy, werden wir überhaupt jemals eine englische Mannschaft erleben, die erfolgreich sein kann. In diesem Stil lief die Pressekonferenz ab und das wurde dann auch bei Twitter gecovert. Schon vorher morgens, das war irgendwie um 10 oder 11 diese PK, schon morgens ging es drauf, wir erwarten, dass Hodgson kommt, es ist peinlich für die FA, der Trainer muss kommen und nur in diesem Stil wurde da getwittert und es war eine völlig andere Atmosphäre als vorher. Und das war irgendwie auch beeindruckend, das einfach mitzuerleben, wie das da abgelaufen ist, weil dann da wurden tatsächlich auch ein bisschen andere Seiten aufgezogen und es war einfach interessant zu sehen, wie er sich da verteidigt hat und was er dann so gesagt hat, auch über die Mannschaft. Und man hat versucht da über Wayne Rooney so eine Intrige in die Mannschaft reinzuspielen und sofort die Pressesprecherin eingeschritten hat gesagt, stopp, stopp, stopp, hat längst wieder dementiert und es stimmt alles gar nicht und es war also ein, diese Pressekonferenz in sich war ein wahnsinniges Schauspiel. Als unbeteiligter, genau, der einfach mitgeschnitten hat und nachher dann einen Beitrag machen konnte mit den besten O-Tönen dieser Pressekonferenz.
Ja, das kann ich mir bildlich vorstellen. Da wäre ich eigentlich auch ganz gerne dabei gewesen. Ihr zwei, vielen lieben Danke. Das ist jetzt, sind jetzt eure letzten Chancen, hier noch irgendwie irgendwas loszuwerden. Denn tatsächlich gehen wir jetzt in die 31. Stunde EM-Berichterstattung im Rasenfunk. Ich muss sagen, jetzt langsam bin ich dann auch mit diesem Turnier durch. Das, was wir hier…
Ich hätte in Spielzeit die Vorrunde fast geschafft, ne?
Ja, und es war wahrscheinlich nur, nur ungefähr gleich langweilig, höchstens. Das können die, können die Hörer beurteilen. Ich muss noch etwas tun, dass ich in der sowohl im letzten Kurzpass, als auch in der letzten Schlusskonzerenz vergessen habe. Ich muss noch ganz kurz den Sieger des Rasenfunk-EM-Tippspiels würdigen, denn immerhin hat er sich gegen 299 andere Tipper durchgesetzt. Herzlichen Glückwunsch Dieter, Unterstrich Detroit, auch zu deinem Nutzernamen. Dieter Detroit hat sich mit 74 Punkten durchgesetzt, was sehr, sehr gut ist, denn wir hatten den einzig wahren Tippmodus, richtiges Ergebnis, drei Punkte, richtige Tendenz, ein Punkt und ansonsten nichts. Ich habe noch den Fehler gemacht, die Bonuspunkte waren noch zu viel, aber lieber höher. Es ist der einzig wahre EM-Tippspielmodus oder auch Tippspielmodus generell und ich kann es beweisen, womit ich bin in unserem Tippspiel neunter geworden mit 64 Punkten und habe fünf meiner sechs anderen Tippspiele gewonnen, die alle mit der Standard-Tipp-Regel waren. Da seht ihr mal, wie knallhart diese Regel ist.
Du hast fünf deiner sechs Tippspiele gewonnen? Fünf von sieben hast du gerade so einfließen lassen, einfach mal so. Das ist ja nicht dein Ernst.
Ja, aber halt im wichtigsten im Rasenfunk-Tippspiel bin ich tatsächlich nur neunter geworden. Da sieht man mal, wie knallhart tatsächlich diese Tippregel ist und deswegen mag ich sie aber auch. Das wird auch zur Bundesliga wieder so laufen und wenn es euch nicht gefällt, liebe Rasenfunk-Hörer, dann müsst ihr in ein Kindergarten-Tippspiel wechseln. Dann seid ihr hier falsch. Jetzt muss ich glaube ich noch die nennen, die acht die vor mir waren oder die sieben neben Dieter Detroit, sonst ist das ganz schön selbstreferenziell. Gratulation an den zweiten, Ferenc I, den dritten Nester, den vierten Trainer Bade, der ist uns hoffentlich allen bekannt, den fünften David NB, den ebenfalls geteilten fünften Lokalmatertor, den fünften Marcian, grüße an der Stelle, den fünften Stefan Tastiko und hinter mir auf Platz zehn dann Schubert129. Vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen, ihr habt sehr sehr gut getippt und es gab genau einen, der Portugal als Europameister vorausgesagt hat. Auch Glückwunsch dazu, nicht so schlecht. Ja und dann glaube ich sollte ich als nächstes euch danken, ihr zwei zum einen mit seinem Rasenfunk-Debüt und ich hoffe es wird nicht deine letzte Aufnahme gewesen sein, auch wenn das jetzt sehr lange und vielleicht ein bisschen anstrengend war. Vielen vielen Dank an Matthias Friebe vom Deutschlandfunk, liebe Hörer. Folgt ihm auf Twitter, es lohnt sich. Et matthias-friebe und außerdem auch der Tipp, die Angebote des Deutschlandfunk sind auch als Podcast erhältlich und gerade die Sportgespräche und die Sportpodcast, da lohnt sich das Abo. Das könntet ihr euch durchaus mal als Ergänzung zu anderen Podcasts noch geben. Matthias, vielen lieben Dank.
Hat mir großen Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich sehr. Und zum wiederholten Male mit dabei, wie gewohnt souverän, sympathisch, nett und man merkt einfach, Tobi, dass man auch mal in sportradio.de öfter hören sollte. Der Ed Runner Tobi bei Twitter. Tobi, vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Und damit würde ich sagen, liebe Hörer, machen wir jetzt dann tatsächlich die EM zu hier im Rasenfunk. Allerdings muss ich noch einen kurzen Dank loswerden. Ihr könnt uns ja unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und an der Stelle möchte ich mal wieder drei Unterstützer danken. Zum einen Markus Ziegler, Jochen Hillebrandt und Christoph Gens. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass ihr uns helft, den Rasenfunk ein bisschen auf finanzielle Beine zu stellen. Und jetzt ist die EM auch wirklich vorbei. Vielen Dank für die treuen Ohren, liebe Hörer. Und wir hören uns dann – nee, ich will eigentlich gar nicht sagen, wann wir uns hören. Keine Ahnung. Spätestens zur Bundesliga-Saison. Ich brauche jetzt auch eine kurze Sommerpause. Macht es gut, ciao! Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.